hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer question from one of my
newsletter readers Jennifer who wrote in
asking me to check out her website
called hocus-pocus pocus kids where it's
for children's clothing on the ground
level up from there check out my site so
we're going to check out the site and
see what we think so the first thing I
would do I she even before checking the
site is I'd always try to add one
sentence if you ever want somebody to
check out your website a lot of times
people won't do it so it's great to add
a sentence to explain what it is that
you do so it's great to this you know
children's clothing but what makes you
unique there's a lot of companies that
do children's clothing so what's so
special about you and your clothes
anytime you're telling anybody about
your your business by email and person
you always want to explain with one
extra sentence what's so special about
your company but we'll figure that go on
to the next page so loading up the page
the first thing I notice is that this
picture is out of focus so I don't know
if it was maybe too small and then you
expanded it to be bigger but the picture
is is blurry and it doesn't make the
company look I guess as professional as
it could be because it's out of focus
again I'm looking on it here and I don't
see one sentence to explain what it is
that you do so it's kids words and
accessories but again why are you
different maybe something in here would
be nice to see I'll click on the home
about us the CEO it shows up not a lot
of detail here hocus-pocus brand new
business survey for 2012 I probably take
that out you usually don't see companies
saying when they got started unless they
got started a long time ago because that
adds to the credibility this might take
away from your credibility if somebody
comes to the site and see kind of blurry
pictures and it's a brand new business
they might think twice about putting
their credit card information in and
making an order for some of your clothes
so I probably take that out as a mother
of designers business to help families
with our beautiful range of brand
clothing very probably brand-name
clothing you're missing there I reduced
prices I know how expensive children's
clothing is especially when our little
angels only want to wear brand names
okay so this is great this story is
pretty good what I try to do here is
expand in a little bit more I'd maybe
include a picture of yourself with the
kids hopefully talk about why you wanted
to start this business in more detail
and explain that I think anybody who
clicks on our own reads it they might
feel a connection to your store any
parent will hopefully read your story
and feel closer to you and then feel a
little bit more comfortable and making a
purchase from your website so i
definitely want to expand on this a
little bit more try to get you know at
least 500 words in here to explain your
story why you got started you know what
your passion is and hopefully someone
who goes through that process will then
want to make a purchase for me let's see
what's happening next the other thing I
noticed here is that the the banner is
the same so it's what a little confused
and I'm not quite sure if I'm on the
same page or not because so much of the
top part of this navigation is the same
from here up but also you want to try to
keep the navigation this banner here
different for each page so this is about
us you know you want to have you or your
kids or pictures other features of the
clothes just shake it up a little bit so
it's not the exact same picture and
every page especially when this picture
is is out of focus let's see what
happens next let's go to boys where I
have a son so let's see whats app down
this page ok so again the same top
navigation with this banner here this
would be a little bit of a turn-off
because I have a son I'm here on the
boys page and I'm seeing girls and you
know bathing suit for girls girls
clothing maybe this is for boys but
again here if you're looking for boys
stuff the picture should be about boys
happy boys pictures of the clothing
whatever it is you should target that
towards your audience
looking at the pictures themselves a
close I see we've got a broken picture
here another broken picture here again
if I'm thinking of buying from you and
if I see a website that's new and the
the pictures are broken I'm probably not
going to give them my credit card or
trust that they're going to deliver the
product to me if I want to click on one
of the products let's try Star Wars I
can't actually click on the product I
click on the picture okay okay so here
there's just the exact same picture so
you not give them any more detail you
definitely expect that that picture
would be a lot bigger and hopefully you
have more text here you should describe
what this is so it says Star Wars pj set
but i'm not quite sure what this is is
this Darth Vader on the cover is this
something else I'm not really sure what
it is so you definitely make this
picture bigger and also have some more
text to explain what that is looking at
the SEO of this page quickly you have
the title saying with your collection
and the URLs winter collection this is
probably not going to get you ranked in
Google you want to have something a
little bit more specific I'd probably
create a new page for each of these
pieces of clothing if you can and call
it you know Star Wars pajama set for
boys ages of whatever the ages would be
for size of three four five that might
get somebody searching and landing on
your page you want to make a purchase
where you're probably never going to
rank for winter collection considering
you're going up against some pretty big
competition so that's my immediate
thought I guess I'm on this boy's page
let's see what else you do check out the
clearance stock probably be popular for
people coming want to see what's
immediately on sale so sleepy time
you're missing a quote here on the page
I click on the picture again the same
thing so again it's just general
professional doesn't look good i
probably wouldn't buy from this site
unless i really really had to have a
specific product that you have that
could
find anywhere else this here click here
to edit looks like you're just templated
stuff that these products don't exist
your if you know if you don't have
anything on here I wouldn't have this
this show up but just take it off and if
the sleepy time is the only thing that's
on sale then just take everything else
off what happens if i click it just
refreshes the page okay so yeah this
should all be removed again it doesn't
add to the credibility of the page you
make the look nice let's see what else
we have parties hocus-pocus party's fun
relax enjoyable so here you actually
have some text so this is good to your
explaining you know this process you
have you have some little more detail
which is great you should add more text
to the other pages which is good
thinking about opening your own business
ask about party planning business
starter ask about our party planner our
business starter sounds a little weird
maybe starter kit or starter package and
you definitely have a link here anytime
you have a call to action you want to
have it links somewhere to your contact
email phone number whatever it is so
they can actually you know follow
through with that I notice here at the
bottom to it says create a website with
Weebly so we believes a great system to
create professional-looking websites
without having a technical background
and overall the site has a lot of
potential looks good i like i like these
little leafy things it looks
professional i like to drop down menus
you don't have to have a lot of
technical skills to work with it again
you could make the pictures and the
descriptions look nicer but the overall
design is not bad but this doesn't look
great I try to see if there's a way to
get this removed it doesn't look good
from again a custom point of view they
come in and they see that you made it as
a free website you know again they're
thinking well if they can't afford to
have a regular website are they going to
really even ship my product if I give
them my credit card information so you
want to make your web your business and
your website seem as credible as
possible so I try to find a way to get
that off but the design does look pretty
good and I think there's a lot to work
with
you have here maybe last last page look
at the contact us so it's great a caso
address phone number email like us on
Facebook I don't see a way to click here
so again if you want and somebody to
take action you want to make sure you
have that link i don't know how would
like you on facebook i don't see
facebook anywhere on your page I'd have
to go to facebook and search for
hocus-pocus kids wear which most people
probably won't do so again you want to
make that super easy to do and yeah
seeing that Weebly thing here again
makes me second-guess the website so try
to find a way to take that off so those
are my initial thoughts I think overall
it's it has a lot of promise I think
what you're trying to do is very good I
think if you can tell your story a
little bit more and have people tune
into that and and read it and hopefully
feel the connection to you and I think
if you can just change around the
pictures improve the quality a little
bit improve the product descriptions a
little bit look at amazon com they're
great you know resource you know they're
selling this kind of stuff but also
everything else see how they do it and
with the reviews and all that kind of
stuff that it's a good best practice to
be able to follow but I think there's a
lot of potential if you do it right so
hopefully that gives you some some good
advice and thanks for allowing us to use
you as a guinea pig for those of you
guys watching if you liked the video and
you want to see more please give it a
thumbs up below it makes you want to do
more videos for you and if you have a
comment about hocus pocus kidswear calm
or if you have a question for your own
business their website feel free to
leave in the comments below I always
read those and I love seeing them come
in so thank you and you'll see you on
the next episode
you